tag drei des militärischen
unterstützungseinsatz es für die läufer
guten tag meine damen und herren
schön dass sie wieder zu schauen
ich bin sehr zufrieden die kräfte haben
hervorragend gearbeitet und ich bin froh
dass man solche übungen durchführen
können
an
wegen der demonstration sie haben es
gerade gehört konnte eine
pressekonferenz vom bundesheer und der
polizei zunächst nicht stattfinden
mit stunden verspätung wurden die
journalisten dann doch noch in den
konferenzraum gelassen
kritischen infrastruktur also wasser
energie verkehr bestimmt unser tägliches
leben und daher ist besonders wichtig
dass wir hier den schutz dieser
kritischen infrastruktur auch im frieden
üben denn klar ist nur was im frieden
geübt wird kann auch im ernstfall
gekonnt werden
josef wie ist die aktion gestern
abgelaufen
die abfahrt aus kufstein nach der
entladung hat sich aus unseren bekannten
gründen verzögert
das war es von uns hoffentlich sehen wir
uns wieder
ich wünsche ihnen einen friedvollen und
erfolgreichen tag